Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today we're going to be doing
another low-level design video backed by
semi-popular demand. Not very popular
though. And uh today we'll be designing
an elevator. Without further ado, let's
get into this low-level design. I've
thought this out at a medium level and
frankly I could have done a much better
job here. So anyway, let's do this.
Okay, so in today's question, we're
going to be designing an elevator
system. And the kind of tough part about
this problem is there's really not that
great of a solution. It's one of those
things where there are many different
types of implementations that we can do
and they all have their benefits and
their trade-offs and we're going to try
and discuss those a little bit. I'm not
going to do a super deep dive. Um there
are videos out there that cover this
problem for 45 minutes, but truthfully,
I think parts of those videos are kind
of overkill and I'm going to try and
just get to the root of the problem
relatively quickly to help you guys out.
Okay, so let's think about the elevator
itself because we know there's got to be
some sort of elevator object. And the
reason that I'm choosing to use an
interface here at least to get started
with is there may perhaps be multiple
different implementations of an
elevator, right? We know there's going
to be this box that lets people in it
and it's going to ride around. But the
way that the elevator chooses where to
go next is potentially going to differ.
We just know that it's going to be
moving around through the elevator
shaft. So with this in mind, I just have
one method that I want us to implement
called move. And basically all that's
going to happen then is the elevator
basically says, okay, what floor am I
going to next? And go ahead and do that.
So basically in addition to that, we
also need some sort of dispatcher
interface. The reason for this is, yeah,
sure, the elevator can basically have
some sort of state telling it where it's
going to move in the future, but
sometimes rides are going to have to be
requested by humans as they, you know,
push a button or two. And the dispatcher
is going to be responsible, generally
speaking, for basically sending new
requests to specific elevators. Now,
depending on our implementation of the
elevator system, this may be either done
passively or actively. So, a passive
dispatcher would basically be waiting
for an elevator to request, you know, a
new passenger. Basically, the elevator
says, "I'm empty. Can you tell me where
to go next?" An active dispatcher would
basically say every single time that
someone who requests a ride presses a
button, it already is going to assign an
elevator to that request the second that
it's made. So, that would be the
difference between kind of an active and
passive dispatcher. And the issue with
that is, you know, it makes defining an
interface tough for this because
essentially those are two completely
different interfaces between the user
and the elevator system, right? In the
passive case, I might just press, you
know, the up button or the down button
and, you know, an elevator is going to
swoop by me at some point and pick me
up. And in the other case, I would
probably press my destination floor and
then I would go ahead and see the
elevator that I have to go to and go to
that elevator. So, it's kind of actually
two different interfaces. So, at least
for now, the interfaces that I'm
defining are assuming kind of um
something like a passive dispatcher
where the elevator is going to wait
until it needs to have more riders and
it's going to ask the dispatcher where
to go next. So, what are some methods
that we can actually go ahead and
define? Well, there's the add elevator
request method, which is going to take
in a current floor and this parameter
moving to. So, I left this purposefully
vague because again, depending on the
type of buttons that you're using,
moving to could either be a destination
floor or it could be something like up
or down. And add elevator request is
basically, you know, what uh the user or
the button would be telling the
dispatcher when they're trying to go
ahead and request a ride from the
elevator. Similarly, we also have this
concept of removing an elevator request.
This is because sometimes requests get
handled. Um, it's going to be the case
that sometimes an elevator may swoop
past someone who has an active request
and just happens to pick them up. And as
a result, it's important that we can
then remove their request so that no
other elevators in the future are going
to go ahead and try and grab them later.
Then we also have this concept of
getting a request to handle. This is
where, you know, in like the passive
case, I as an elevator am going to ask
the dispatcher for the next request to
be handled. And it is the dispatcher's
job to basically do some sort of logic
or have some sort of state that it is
going to tell me where I should go next
to pick up my next passenger. And then
also we have this concept of has
unfulfilled request. And this is going
to come in handy basically if I'm an
elevator and I'm passing by a floor and
I want to check if there's an active
request there where I can pick this
person up potentially and go ahead and
you know kind of add them to my existing
elevator ride in order to kind of
parallelize the number of passengers
that we have. But let's move onwards a
little bit. So another uh aspect of kind
of object-oriented programming that I
personally have debated here is whether
we need a button class. I think that um
you certainly can use buttons and this
is obviously something that you want to
work out with your interviewer. But the
only reason that you would want to make
an explicit button class is if the
buttons themselves need to have state.
So, in reality, when you press a button
uh when you're waiting for an elevator,
typically it'll do things like light up
and you know, when that request is
handled or when the elevator comes to
get you, the button will stop being lit
up. So, in an example where we care
about the state of those buttons, then
obviously we do want objects
representing each of them. However, in
our basic elevator system, I'm going to
imagine that even though there are
buttons, what the passenger is really
doing is just calling a dispatcher
method to add a request. And so as a
result, I've chosen to not involve
buttons in this to try and simplify the
problem for us. But if it did come down
to it, we could obviously have a bunch
of these buttons where, you know, there
would obviously need to be some sort of
method to uh communicate with the dish
dispatcher service to add a request and
also there would need to be some way for
the dispatcher service to communicate
back with each button once a request has
been handled or you know is starting to
be handled. And then the button could
maybe turn off uh its light or something
like that. So again, I'm purposely
leaving these out of this problem in
order to, you know, stop it from getting
too overly complicated. I'm just leaving
this to elevators and a dispatcher
service for now. But, you know, in a
real world, obviously, there's going to
need to be some sort of button classes.
Okay. So, uh, one comment that I
received on my last video was to kind
of, you know, exemplify how dependencies
were passed together, um, and, you know,
look at the actual driver code just to
go ahead and wrap things together.
Basically, we know we're just going to
have one dispatcher service cuz that's
going to be a centralized thing where
all the requests are handled. And then
I'm imagining that the dispatcher
service is going to be passed into each
instance of an elevator that's created.
I've created two here, but you could
obviously create, you know, three more,
you know, 100 million, whatever. We're
assuming that our elevator system is,
you know, potentially potentially
limitless because if it were a finite
size, then the complexity of our oper
operations wouldn't really matter very
much. Um, additionally, uh, I'm not
going to talk about it very much in this
problem, but again, if you know, if we
assume we have like a million floors or
something and 10,000 elevators, we could
in theory almost shard up the floors
such that each elevator is handling
different parts of those floors. But I
think for the sake of this problem,
that's probably not too important and
it's kind of an afterthought for this. I
think if your interviewer was asking you
about that, uh, you know, it starts
becoming a very different problem. And
this is more just about the design in
general. So all we're going to do in the
main method is just run a while loop
where we're calling move for each of the
elevators. It's possible that uh these
methods would be running concurrently in
reality. And if that's the case, we're
going to need some amount of locks in
order to make sure that the same request
isn't being sent out to multiple
elevators. Um but for now, I'm assuming
that, you know, we're just running this
in a single threaded system. And again,
that should hopefully simplify things a
little bit so that we don't have to
think about locking.
Okay. So what is a naive elevator
implementation? Right? Because I I
mentioned that all the elevator really
needs to have is this one method called
move. That's really all effectively that
an elevator is doing is it moves from
place to place. Uh it changes direction
potentially and it opens and closes its
doors. I didn't even really cover the
opening and closing of doors in this
problem, but I'm just assuming that
whenever the elevator is idle, it's
going to open its doors or whenever it
uh you know whenever it switches floors
basically and uh picks up a passenger or
drops off a passenger. I'm just assuming
it's opening up its doors. But
basically, we have this concept of a
naive elevator implementation. So, the
easiest way for an elevator to work is
we just handle one request at a time,
right? We basically take them in as if
there were a queue. The elevator would
hold one request locally where it would
go to a floor, it would open its doors,
it would go to a floor, it would open
its doors, and every single time that it
drops off a passenger, it would then
again just, you know, receive a floor to
go to and go ahead and do that. It's not
overly challenging. And the reason this
obviously isn't going to be very good is
because we're traveling a lot of
redundant distances. And what do I mean
by that? Well, let's imagine that
basically I'm in the elevator. That's me
in the gray box right there. And I'm
going upwards. And then, you know, we
see that there's this passenger Elon who
could also be picked up in a matter such
that, you know, we're now traveling
duplicate distances between, you know,
where he wants to be picked up and my
destination. So we would minimize the
distance traveled by the elevator in the
event where I'm picking up Elon and I'm
also dropping him off at his own
destination if we do that during the
course of my route. So doing this we can
basically handle a few requests in
parallel and we don't just have to
handle one request at a time and then go
ahead and you know handle another that
wouldn't be very efficient. So let's
look at some code that might actually be
able to implement some logic like this.
Okay, so as you can see um here we have
our kind of elevator algorithm
implementation. We know we have some
local dispatcher and for now I've called
this a FIFO dispatcher which at least
for me means that it is going to
basically uh give you all of the
requests that haven't been handled in
the order that they were submitted. So
again it's just going to be a Q
dispatcher but we can talk about
different types of dispatchers later in
the video and I'm planning on doing so.
Additionally, we're going to have this
uh basically local element called floors
to visit. And floors to visit is just a
list of all the places that the elevator
has to go. Um I'm implementing that as
basically a doubly linked list with a
hashmap. The reasoning for this being
that not only do we want to be able to
remove kind of from anywhere in that
doubly linked list in constant time, but
we also want to be able to quickly see
if things are in there. And uh we'll
speak about that a bit more. And then we
also have this concept of current floor
and current direction because this is
going to help us determine whether we
should pick up a rider and the direction
that we're currently moving in. So
basically we're going to do the
following. Um if there are no floors
that we need to visit, all we're going
to do is ask our dispatcher for, you
know, basically the next request up.
Recall that our dispatcher is a FIFO Q,
which means that we're just going to be
getting the, you know, the first request
that was sent in chronologically. And
then we would go ahead and add that to
floors to visit and basically go ahead
and set our direction because the
direction is going to be corresponding
to whether the passenger pressed up or
down. So we're going to be getting that
from uh basically our dispatching
service. And then from there again uh
the next floor that we want to be
visiting uh where we're assuming floors
to visit is a que. We're just going to
go ahead and pop from the queue and then
use a while loop to go ahead and loop
from our current floor towards the next
floor um based on kind of the current
direction. And then finally, we're going
to say every single time that we go
ahead and go up and down a floor uh
towards our destination floor, we're
basically going to check if there is a
request from that floor in the direction
where we're currently going. Right? So,
if we're going down and we pass a floor
and there's someone who wants to be
going down from that floor that we pass,
we're going to go ahead and pick them up
and push their destination floor to the
queue. Right here, I'm kind of making an
oversimplification in the sense that I'm
assuming that the passenger is kind of
coming in and definitely pressing a
floor that's in the direction that they
indicated by the elevator buttons. In
reality, that's something they don't
necessarily have to do. But the point is
the passenger is now going to you know
also give some sort of floor that they
press within the elevator and we're
going to put that at the back of our
queue. We want to visit it eventually.
And then another aspect of this is as
we're actually moving in the elevator.
If the current floor that we're on is
going to be a floor that is in our
floors to visit hash q, it means that
somebody in our elevator wants to get
out at that floor and we should stop and
remove that floor from floors to visit
and let that person get out. Um, again,
I'm kind of, you know, taking out of the
problem the aspect of actually stopping,
opening the doors, etc., etc. That's not
too hard. You can add that all back in.
But by saying floors to visit remove
current floor, I'm insinuating that the
passenger is getting out right there. So
basically, we keep doing this until we
run out of floors to visit, at which
point we ask the dispatcher Q for
another place to go. This is kind of
known as the scan elevator algorithm.
The reasoning being that you basically
just keep moving in the same direction
until you're out of places to go and
then you can ask for a new place to go.
Uh, some variations of this are as
opposed to like ever stopping and
potentially changing directions when
you're out of places, you could just go
all the way from the bottom of the
building all the way to the top and back
down and back up and back down again.
But that potentially means that you're
going to be wasting some travel time.
Okay, so what are some issues with the
previous implementation of the elevator
class that I just described? Well, there
are a couple. Uh the first is that for
code simplicity I decided to basically
run a while loop of you know all the
floors from our current floor to our
destination floor so that at every
intermediate floor we could check if
there are passengers to pick up or if
there are passengers to let out. Um
however this could technically be
improved algorithmically. The reasoning
being that you know let's say our
building has a million floors and I want
to go from floor 900,000 to floor
500,000. That means I'm running through
400,000 iterations of a while loop. But
what if there were only two potential,
you know, passengers that entire time?
Well, that's kind of a big issue. So, it
would probably be better if we could
just go ahead and iterate uh through the
actual requests that are still outgoing
and the current passengers in order to
figure out where to actually stop at and
use the logic there. Um something like a
binary search tree here would be hugely
helpful in the sense that um you know
from one node in a binary search tree we
can easily figure out all of the nodes
um you know that are greater than it and
also less than some other node in the
binary search tree. So to put that, you
know, in kind of a more concrete
example, if I'm going from the 20th
floor to the 40th floor, and I have all
the dispatcher requests in one single
binary search tree, it means that I can
go ahead and figure out all of the
requests uh in the dispatcher that are
between 20 and 40 in linear time
complexity, which is really, really
good. Um, in fact, even better than
linear time complexity because you just
go to 20 and 40 in the binary search
tree and then you basically get all the
nodes between them. Um, another issue
that I didn't really talk about too much
because I've just kind of assumed so far
that the dispatch scheduler is um a FIFO
Q is that we could have starvation. So,
what if the dispatcher wasn't something
where it was just first request is the
next one handled and instead it was, you
know, if you're an elevator and you
don't have any passengers to handle, go
ahead and handle the request that's
closest to you. Now, let's imagine
there's one guy who's been waiting at
the lobby of a building and all the
other requests are popping in at the
100th floor. the guy at the lobby could
have been waiting for an hour because
the elevator just keeps servicing all
those requests, you know, from the 90th
to the 100th floor and bouncing back up
there and then the lobby request gets
starved. So, it's important to kind of
think about how we actually build out
our dispatcher in order to make sure
that we're not going to be starving
specific requests. So, with this in
mind, what would actually be a
starvation free dispatch service that is
also algorithmically sound? Well, I kind
of described it before with that idea of
a FIFO dispatch service, but the general
point is we can again use a doubly
linked list and a hashmap. The reasoning
for this being that we can, you know,
easily pull the first thing out of that
doubly linked list, that's going to be
the oldest request. So, it works as a Q.
But also if we just happen to randomly
service a job because we were very close
to it or because you know we passed the
floor that that request was coming from
and just happened to pick that guy up.
We can then remove from an arbitrary
place in that doubly linked list and
hashmap combination in o of one time
which is really great. One issue with
this however is that just doing a fo
dispatcher uh doesn't account for the
actual distance that an elevator has to
travel in order to handle that next
request. So, let's imagine that um you
know we have a really tall building and
we have two elevators and one elevator
is all the way at the bottom and one
elevator is all the way at the top and
the top elevator asks the dispatch
service for the next request to get and
the next request to get happens to be
from the lobby and the bottom request
service asks for the one after that and
that happens to be all the way at the
top of the building. Now we have two
elevators going in the complete opposite
directions of one another all the way
across the building and wasting a ton of
distance traveled. It would be better if
we could somehow take into account not
only the time that a request has been
waiting but also the distance that the
elevator has to travel to service it so
that we both don't have starvation but
also minimize distance traveled by an
elevator. Um this would be something
like a starvation free and
distanceconscious dispatch service. That
is a lot to say, but the general point
is we would just create some sort of
metric that takes into account both
distance to the actual request from the
elevator's current location and also the
time since each request. And this is
really great. It should, you know,
minimize the amount of distance traveled
while also not starting jobs. However,
it comes at the cost of being
algorithmically inefficient in the sense
that we now have to calculate our
heruristic for every single one of the
open requests because it's not like we
can use a priority queue here since the
amount of time is always changing since
a request has been made and so is the
distance to any given elevator. So
basically, we'd have to iterate over all
open requests whenever an elevator is
like, "Can I find a new person to pick
up?" And that could take a lot of time
if there are a lot of requests. But this
is another alternative option that you
could in theory discuss in your
interview. And then finally, the last
thing that I want to quickly touch upon,
which I touched upon a little bit
earlier in the video, is the fact that
some of these elevator systems are built
a little bit differently where you don't
just press up or down when you get in,
but rather when you're actually
requesting an elevator, you punch in
your destination floor. There would be
like a keypad or something, and then the
dispatcher system would actually assign
you an elevator from the beginning. So,
if this was to be the case where we
decided to go with this type of service,
well, there are a couple of interesting
things to think about. Um, and I'm not
going to get into this too much because
I think it's honestly a little bit
beyond the scope of this interview or
this interview question. Um, but the
first question would obviously be what
type of interface are you looking at?
And it would be quite a bit different,
right? Like the dispatcher service every
single time you pressed a button would
have to actively assign you an elevator
and then your floor would go into that
elevator's queue of floors to visit. But
more importantly, another good question
would be what type of heruristic would
we actually use as the dispatcher
service to determine what elevator is
going to service which request. We don't
care about the time since the request
has been made anymore simply because of
the fact that uh the elevator is going
to be assigned instantly right after the
request has been made. So time since the
request now becomes inevitable. We'd
probably be thinking more about things
like you know the capacity of each
elevator. We would be thinking about um
things like the distance from the
elevator to the person. And again, the
dispatcher service, this would
potentially be a linear time operation
over the number of elevators. So if you
have millions and millions of elevators,
the dispatcher service has to loop
through all of them, you know, calculate
some result of a heristic and then
assign that request to one of those
elevators. So that is something to keep
in mind. In conclusion, though, this is
obviously a hard and very open-ended
problem. There are multiple different
implementations of elevators and that's
because there's not one that's
objectively correct. This isn't like
tic-tac-toe where there's just a pretty
easy straightforward answer once you
have the class system down uh in terms
of algorithms. It's actually the case
that um you know depending on which
elevator style you choose, we might have
a completely different interface. And uh
so in conclusion, uh the slide says it,
but elevators blow and so do I, but a
lot of guys. All right, guys. Well,
that's all for today's video.
Fortunately, it is getting cold enough
here in New York such that I stopped
sweating every single time I record,
which is a real good thing for me. Um,
but yeah, I'll see you in the next one.
Again, let me know how I can improve
this series further. I understand this
is very open-ended and it's hard for me
to even necessarily come up with the
answers sometimes uh that are
satisfactory to everyone, but I will
continue to do what I can.